who's looking forward to the weekend uh
me yeah yeah the Good Morning America
romance Saga comes to an end T.J Holmes
and Amy robach are leaving the Anchor's
desk for good the network says after
several productive conversations we all
agreed it's best for everyone that they
move on from ABC News
ET Source says no one wanted it to come
to this our sources say the couple
blames this outcome on derogatory
information being gossiped about during
the week's long investigation which
ultimately led to a crucial mediation
session on Thursday the meeting followed
reports TJ had a third office affair
while he was still with estranged wife
Marilee phoebec I want everybody to get
married I think everybody should since
they were taking off the air in November
an Insider says TJ's issues got all the
headlines but Amy is No Angel the day
after the mediation new allegations
against Amy surfaced reports she was
drinking on the job and showing up to
work intoxicated but a source close to
Amy calls the accusations absurd and if
true that behavior would have shown
through several years ago another tip is
to train with friends
and the source adds all Amy is really at
fault for is falling for her colleague
and she's always been professional
keeping the romance alive in any
relationship well maybe it's a challenge
these days just a little bit sometimes
right marriage gets a bad rap a lot of
times when news of the romance broke
last year an Insider told E.T that Amy
and TJ bonded over their love of running
here's my half marathon tip ask her for
tips so stop we're never gonna get
through this I thought we were done and
another source revealed they grew closer
while co-hosting gma's third hour your
marriage was like a plant you have to
water it every day that's a marriage
segment or a landscaping segment this is
the Platinum party at the palace and
meanwhile the relationship seemingly
continues they were spotted spending
time together over the holidays
it always gets into the holiday spirit
why do I tell you things in confidence
TJ and Mary Lee along with Amy and her
estranged husband Andrew Shu have been
separated for months Andrew and I are in
our second marriage we have a blended
family we have step children it was not
easy and sometimes it still isn't easy
[Music]
thank you